today I'd like to talk about studying
the Showman
many of you may know more than myself
but
if you build your own dojo
and you decorate it the way you feel
it should be decorated so it becomes a
very personal thing
it's a place of a sanctuary for yourself
and I know that teachers that have a
permanent dojo
whether designated shown them
finding the place where they
sent to her their self and
perhaps he could say find out who they
are
in the quiet times when they sit
on their own
in 1992
I was fortunate enough to have
Shihan Pat Hendrix
come to the UK
and as she
has flown in Japanese
as well as off at her time in those days
as a Japanese translator
into English
she also knew
a special ceremony that had to take
place
if you have a Shinto house
such as I do
here in the dojo
the Shinto house
is
in many houses in Japan
it's a Shinto religion that I do not
follow myself
but many Japanese do
and like people that meditate
in their own homes they may find a small
space
where they they make a small shrine
and put josticks and things that they
like to Center their self
and they may meditate each morning or
evening
in front of their designated
I think we can say Ulta
I personally don't follow or believe in
any one religion
therefore it's a little bit odd that I'm
going to explain
the system
I first wanted the house really just for
being more authentic
and following the Japanese
system such as our Sensi in iwama built
his Showman
and he would pray
to the gods each day and child and it
was very religious person
and that he said that to bring Heaven
and Earth together
you need the help from the coming the
Gods
so I'd like to go
um for my sense his picture
that was to draw
specifically for myself so if you see it
anywhere else in the world
a lot of the original
and it was designed and drawn by
Jan Hardy one of the agidoka who's still
training today
so I'm very honored to have such a
beautiful
[Music]
beloved is a bronze Bell
I use the Bell purposely in before I
start meditation
but you can use it to awaken the Gods
so
if I was to take the Bell and the small
Striker next to it
resting at the moment in its try
and if I was sitting on the storm that
is there on the ground on the mat
I would ring the bell
three times
and I've no idea why but I would bring
it slightly louder by hitting it firmer
each time
and those are the bowel resonates
I think of sinking down and down inside
myself
as the waves
fade
it vibrates the inner body and not just
listening to the Rain
with the ears so I'll use it personally
as a combination of going deeper into
what I call the trumpets state
that I have a crystal next to this
nothing to do like you know but I like
the crystal
time so you find the objects that you
have on your shoulder are normally gifts
if they're not part of the
and
set up
that Buddha was given to me by an
archidi student
and so were the small sake bottles
in the Triangular below
moving over to the center the main
one
you can see the house
the candles were given to me by another
aikidoka a teacher from Scotland
and they're very beautiful
and I like them occasionally
if I'm going to do something serious or
award people with their
downgrade certificates
and I do a special ceremony
some
the house
I'll say the house rather than the
Japanese names
covered all different sizes as I said
and people in Japan make a small shine
their house when
the same setup is as you'll see there
and this is where they would say their
prayers or pray to the Gods
to help them in their daily life
you'll notice that the two of ours is
either side
and below in the Triangle
there's pots
and you would have sold
lies
I can't remember what's in the middle
one
but everything you say
is part of the ceremony that you
when you purchase one of these new uh
I think they're cold
houses and they come in all different
sizes and shaves
you would
have a blast such as I had it blessed by
Scentsy and roots and
from then on the house was never touched
the Earth
he must always keep it above the floor
you must not put it on the floor and
this is the tradition
floods has been blessed
the silver destined in front of the main
doorway
is to ward off evil spirits away from
them the Gods
some have a very small house with one
door and this means that you would have
the the one coming in there
the one God
if in this case you have three doors
taken house
three
counts
I'm going to talk about
um the effects and the value that I see
in this system
and as I repeat I don't follow a
religion Shinto or otherwise
personally but I do
have superstitions not so many and I do
have my beliefs what will be
covered in another
film at the back of the bottom triangle
there's a small geisha girl
and this was again given to me by a very
dear friend a lady that has now passed
on to the spirit world
and I keep it for remembering her
and the warmth that she would give to
others
passing over to the next try in the
golden Shelf
you'll notice that the the square
with the flat top
that is
next to the weapon Scrolls
this you put the fruits on when you're
doing the sun on this and if you look up
a cytosensis wake when he passed away
you will see all of this in action
or you can just look up Shinto
traditions and
ceremonies and you will see the Shinto
months
carry out with massive
ones of these
with food and an abundance of things
often being offered up to the Gods
and they're saying everything was down
and it was paid for by people around the
world
in hopes that they could move a sanity
from the normal being to become like a I
use the word martyr a higher place in
the spirit world
whether that happened or not it's up to
each of us to believe it or not to
believe it but there was a special
soundly done to trying ways into a
higher vibration and a higher spiritual
plane
that may be a ceremony somewhere on
YouTube I'm no idea I've never found it
getting on to the Scrolls you'll notice
there's four there
and Below them is a is a a live blade a
tanto
the game was a gift from my student
I
was awarded the first goal
paid for it but we were close to going
on a seminar and since he said he was
very tired and could he send it I agreed
thanked him and the fifth is the highest
landlord but sadly I never got it
and you may not believe this but even
been an adult in front of us like a
sensei
I felt like a small child even though I
was a an adult
and in 1994
I still couldn't ask him where is my
certificate
I wish I had it done but but it's past
now but I do home all five
and have witnesses that that um well
they have at the time
on my obtaining them
below it is another gift from a Russian
student that has green tea in it the
little white pot
next to it is a book that I used to take
with me around the world
and see
twice a year for 19 years at different
places in the world and when something
struck me as an important thing to note
on dry notes in this book
just to find that when I come home
I didn't know what I'd written down
because I couldn't understand
some of the things I can and some things
in that book I can't
and of course the gift again at the end
is from another the the rolling down
Banner if from another very close
student of mine
uh the weapons are new but I do also
have the Ken and Jones still that in
cytosensei chose for me that wasn't
man-made in imama
but they're not on the showman now
I place the meditation still there for
the next part
of the film thank you for listening
or have you found it a worth